my grandmother
bought me a schwinn bike
and the guy recommended that
i get a helmet and my grandmother said
well that's two gifts so pick the
[ __ ] bike or pick the helmet wow
because that's two things
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
i gotta
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
support for the oh my god hi podcast is
brought to you in part by our friends at
bluechew guys it is all about confidence
when it's time for sex am i right
sometimes stress can affect your
performance and ruin the fun thankfully
bluechew.com is here to the rescue try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code omghi at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code omghi to receive your first
month free
i have to i have this brand of beer it's
pretty good i can here you take the one
that fell
this is very popular be careful with
that amongst the natives
i don't drink i'm too good at it
[ __ ] find the guys that have seen the
light
they hit their peak although oh
cheers and that one appears it was a pig
what is that that you're drinking you
hit your peak and your valley water no
no the other one can you see here oh yes
kratom and cava
sponsored by these fools
okay so
let's talk about that okay very well
let's introduce a guest the grand theft
auto yeah absolutely joining us we'll
talk for an hour and not say who's here
we have we have done that uh joining us
on the podcast we have tony hawk and
jason ellis of the hawk versus wolf
podcast on top
you know the many other things you
probably know them from but we'll get
into that both
i would say living legends and so so you
guys podcast says hawk vs who wins hog
versus wolf if they could if they threw
down on a level playing field damn what
do you mean damn it's just some reason
because finally the answer is me
[Laughter]
everything else he wins but that one i
win easily you're all
yeah but i thought you meant like
intellectually or oh [ __ ] no i just once
again
fight let's fight you know
so so i've seen i live up in the hills
over there
by the observatory i've seen i've seen
wolves over there that look like they
haven't eaten in [ __ ] 17 years yeah
they'll eat they'll eat a person now
because they're scrounging around
and uh coyotes too and then
i have my own hawk in the neighborhood
that has had kids i guess little hawks
but this when i first moved into the
house i was laying down i could see
the top of the telephone pole and it had
looked like somebody had their back to
me and i said is there a [ __ ] little
kid up there eating a sandwich on top of
that telephone pole it was a hawk with
his back turned that's where he goes to
eat be a wild kid if it was a kid i know
what they're eating that's terrifying
when we were kids we'd
go to the top of the house and eat
somewhere where nobody could find you
but then i didn't realize it was a it
was a hawk and that thing was [ __ ]
massive man his back he was like this
turn and that thing was [ __ ] huge
we're very intimidating we're very
similar right tony tony likes to eat
children on the top of cliffs cliffs
not just sandwiches just sandwiches if
anybody trips in the hills i will eat
you too [ __ ] hey man you got to be
eater be eat or be eaten that's right i
just get tired
climbing to the top so
yeah so you know as chicanos i've been
on a skateboard i'm going to say that
you probably
please
until it broke in the middle
the the um
um first of all congratulations you and
i
are in the california he just told
[Laughter]
we are the last ones
um
you know i i did you fall at the
induction of the california hall of fame
on the skateboard
no i mean i fall a lot yeah
uh
well yeah i mean most likely because
they had a little ramp
but it wasn't secure it's funny because
he just said that i said i said yeah i'm
walking on the red carpet and then
there's a little mini ramp and all these
kids skating and he's like i bet they
didn't make george do stand up on the
red carpet right it's kind of [ __ ]
don't you think they put a low rider
there so they go hey jordan's a low
rider
so they didn't they didn't have me do
stuff which they would have they would
be equivalent if they would have a
microphone hey thank you everybody for
coming out how about that rupaul huh
yeah
yeah
yeah so obviously they're all they
didn't say that word to anybody
so obviously as i walked by they're all
the kids like hey
you know like okay i'll skate and then i
think i tried to i tried to drop from
the railing yeah and then i did like
they had a they had a railing mini ramp
right something like four foot railing
and then i did tail drop from there and
of course she did and washed out the
first time yeah that's that's necessary
tony but it wasn't wasn't that bad but
they speak like paramedics
like i just skateboarding i went down
and i turned my
head on the sidewalk it's stuck to
skateboard we're pretty close to doctors
yeah when it comes to certain brakes and
torn ligaments we know
better like if you tell a doctor when
you get there you know what the injury
is they find that to be a little bit
rude and we know that we've been so many
times
but if i say hey man i i mean i i blew
my acl out they're like
we'll find out about that and i'm like
i've done it seven times like this this
i know but you you just wait for them to
tell you um let's go over a list of all
the injuries that each one of us have
you want to go first
a rip a torn
my kidneys gone they cancer in the
kidney i have both knees replaced you're
a cancer survivor yeah and i've had
something over here and they called it
watchman you threw them
take your time
take my time
so you had a kidney removed you had i
didn't know you had cancer you just said
you had a kidney removal i had cancer
any kidneys
renal carcinoma my right kidney they
removed my right kidney doctor asked me
you want to take the mass out i said
take the whole thing you know i don't
want you to no i want you to leave it in
i don't want you to cut out a piece and
then tell me later on yeah we didn't get
it all yeah i could live with one and so
that's what he did and so he took that
one out and
three weeks later i was back to work i
mean i was lucky it was early detection
they caught it on a body scan
and
i asked the doc when i went back to see
him you know he says hey
you're perfect you you just proved that
modern medicine coupled with positive
thinking
i mean you're great i'd ask where the
message is
i didn't ask for [ __ ] quotes about
life
i never wanted to
work see a flower three weeks so then
you would tap in your heart after that
yeah i've had a watchman
uh a swatch man a watchman it's like a
little parachute they stick in one of
the
uh
appendages on my heart in the valves so
it so i won't get a stroke where this is
where blood clots fall okay yeah
speaking of language yeah i've had a
heart attack yeah i have uh did they go
into your penis or their little three on
the side yeah they go in the groin
that's what they did to me right uh i
had they went right into the nation i've
had a blazer you go up and you grind all
the way up to there and then they burn
they've fused a valve
apparently it's amazing what they can do
that's crazy because i woke up good to
go oh man so they uh they did that i've
had an ablation i've had a cardioversion
and then they did this thing and that's
that blocks it so i don't get any blood
clots okay because of uh afib you know
yeah me too yeah so that takes care of
that and then i've had both knees
replaced both of them are made out of
titanium i got one knee replacement yeah
they
do you ever no longer
you're you're no longer an assassin from
the liability to the department
yeah so that's that's what pushed me out
and
everything else i appreciate you working
what's more painful
getting caught getting your dick caught
in your zipper or a knee replacement
that's a really good question
what no doubt yeah the knee replacement
i never took after never took anything
for pain i have a high pain tolerance
never took anything for pain for my
kidney uh
you mess with my dick and it's gonna
hurt you
and i got i got i got 10 pounds of extra
foreskin just laying there
we'll make sandwiches later wow that was
a lot
uh
i'm sure you got do you use thc
uh no not really this is a vix
mentholatum rub that has cbd and thc
it's a pain it's a pain reliever oh wow
and this is quite incredible yeah so
that it is the bomb but that means it's
just it doesn't get you high no but it
takes away but it takes away the pain
man yeah i mean you know i do cbd and
thc
all day
but as i'm sore as a rub that use it at
night all right
and uh i guarantee you that i swear by
it that it that it works because i know
because i know as you get older you know
i tore my achilles head some arthritis
and achilles in the morning if you know
i went to a chiropractor and then it
doesn't take away and this at night
relieves the ache in it and it uh the
scar tissue that doesn't hurt as much
but but yes and if you try the ice bath
no no it's the future
it is yeah like if you want to recover
if you want to stay young want to stay
in yeah just go in the ice bath it's
hardcore but yeah it works yeah three
minutes
wow three minutes of you have a nice
bath at your house yeah i got him one
too tell me one yeah oh so there's a
next there's an actual yeah it's got to
the point i used to have a free a meat
freezer i just filled it up with water
and i would have a temperature gauge in
the water so i knew what temperature it
was all the time i had a timer on it so
it would stay the right temp a couple
times i forgot and turned the whole
thing into a giant ice block which
cracked the fridge and made it leak so
note to self don't do that but then i
found through another friend there's
like an actual it's called cold plunge
and it has a filter and stays the ten
and it's like a real it's a really nice
look pad how how big is it we're gonna
put a picture of it but how about how
big is it it's the same as the top yeah
do they come in extra large you'd fit in
it didn't yeah calm down you're alright
but you would just need that much ice
though
funny right after week right after we
got ours uh we have a bunch of kids and
they were all home from college and then
we looked outside and they're all daring
each other and timing each other see how
long they could do it
it's odd yeah and
and what it does to you explain to me
what it does to your body lots of things
i mean first of all inflammation it
takes that down but also there's like a
scientific thing that for me i use it
because i'm sore all the time but i also
use it to
help with my moods because i'm a
emotional guy and if i go in there if
i'm having a bad day and i go in there
for three minutes i'm just a little bit
happier that's just the fact
so it helps with your
immune system helps with a lot of stuff
but i feel like it may i do the sauna
and then i do that because it's easier
to get in there really hot yeah instead
of just
going in there
if you go on the side and you're really
hot and you're like man that's so hot i
would do anything to be cold i got
something for you get on the front
so it's almost like when you're running
somebody throws the ball ahead of time
you have to catch it so you're hot so
when you get in there it's a better idea
it's better yeah it makes it easier if
you're going to do it every day it makes
it way easier does it make its own ice
it's not it's not that soft oh no no no
if it goes to because this one
you see the one where they have water
and they put ice in it but you make it
cold
it stays cold
don't be afraid george just get in there
come on do it three minutes is a long
three minutes a long time it is one
minute no worries the next two yeah not
so good so you probably work up to
you don't know what they're from i just
cast three minutes i just cast and talk
my neighbors probably freak out because
yeah people do the breathing exercises
yeah and i've tried that it is good but
i've i find if i just say [ __ ] a lot
what the [ __ ] am i doing [ __ ] that makes
you breathe this is ridiculous
that's how i get three minutes like what
injuries have you had
i mean i can't keep up but i've torn
my ligaments had a knee replacement on
one knee i've had bone spurs in my
ankles snapped my tailbone
um i've been knocked out too many times
like over 20.
broke both my wrists like six or seven
times broke my shoulder dislocated my
shoulders separated my shoulder
torn all my in my ligaments all my
tendons all my
all that stuff i've got a bone spur in
the joint of my shoulder i just found
out like a week ago
but i went to colombia and got stem
cells so that [ __ ]
i'm a i'm a mess but i work on
rehabilitation
so i'm pretty for 50 i'm pretty good so
can you run
yeah
you absolutely listen man you walk you
don't walk with a limp there's no
noticeable
actually a little bit right now but
that's because i skated with him
yesterday and i ate [ __ ] a bunch of
times so so why do you gotta throw a man
into the mix
it's like it's like flying it wasn't his
job it was totally my fault all right
flying with chuck yeager hey man i'm not
that good a flyer come on [ __ ]
so so
in the when george bush i think the
first push was was in office he he
rejected stem cell uh yeah you can't get
it here you can't get it here you get it
out of your own body here which means
there's not enough stem they take it out
of your spine and then they spin it on
this platelet thing i did it in my knee
here
but they in colombia they take it from
the umbilical cord so they they check
the parents and then when the baby's
born they take the uh the placenta and
the umbilical cord and they take the
stem cells out of that and then the stem
cells you get are
like i got 40 million in my shoulder 40
million in each knee a hundred million
in an iv and when you get it in your
back i got like a hundred thousand
and and how do you guys feel when you
have that done after you have the
procedure i didn't do that but i did i
did my knee um with my own is it blood
spinning they call it
that's what they drp that's yeah prp i
did that in my knee um when they put it
in my knee it was the most pain i've
ever been in honestly because it felt
like they were it felt like they were
taking a wedge just pulling my my uh
patella up yeah no anesthesia big fat
needle right yeah but then i was skating
so i had torn my pcl i was skating two
weeks later oh wow without even worrying
about it and it's your body doing it
they have to put it in there yeah i
don't know i don't pretend to understand
the technology it regrows and it regrows
because the first blood that blood from
the placenta is the purest blood of all
like because it's
doesn't i'm not i don't know exactly how
it works i just know that it takes away
the inflammation which means there's the
pain is gone but then it it's been
proven to regrow
like if you tell your tendons a lot you
go they if you snap it you get surgery
you can get stem cell where if it's
still attached somewhat it over a period
of a year it will grow bigger and
stronger and tighten up again it's
i think you're [ __ ] crazy it's funny
you think people have ulterior motives
like you know that probably the medical
whatever the medical pharmaceutical in
this country would say well if they do
that people are going to heal we don't
want people to heal now they want you to
have the surgery they want you to have
pills they want to have surgeries okay
and that's why because kobe bryant went
to germany and had it done years ago lee
trivino went and had stem cell also a
procedure where they put like rollers in
your in your back
and because he had a spawn and he had a
spine and she got it by lightning twice
but he couldn't walk up the stairs
couldn't uh walk couldn't sound like old
lady what time i called his house he's
like hello i say senoras lee there he
goes it's me
he's just so much pain that he didn't
sound like himself and then he went to
germany or wherever i'm sure where they
do it and now he walks he's 82 years old
it's amazing
yeah it got me to skate again
and and uh
in all the in all those injuries did you
immediately know because i think you
know your body but do you know what's
wrong with if i fell and hurt myself i
wouldn't know that i didn't mind if we
talked about it when we get hurt it's
more of a
uh i'm pissed because i know what's
coming next because i know what the
injury is and i know what the rehab is
and i know the surgery
so it's not it's never the
pain it's more like [ __ ] that's like six
months exactly
i know it's six months i know it's rehab
i know it's all this other [ __ ] did you
box as a career or did you box as a
hobby i got into boxing when i moved up
to hollywood to be a radio host and
there was no vote ramp so i
got into mixed martial arts to fill the
gap of not being a skateboarder anymore
and then because i'm such an idiot like
as soon as i got into fighting and i met
real fighters i was like whoa
real fight sounds
crazy like i want to do that and then
next thing you know i'm a [ __ ] old
man that's like signing up to be a pro
mma fighter people are like what are you
doing here and i'm like just want the
experience man they're like you're gonna
get an experience i just don't know if
you want that but but do you like
getting it i love it i think so i saw i
saw some video i said this dude
there's a dude that you punched straight
in the face you had like a smurf you
said and you said i'll break your hand
i'm gonna wipe those [ __ ] down
yeah and i'll eat your hands i thought
this guy is one of those dudes
yeah it's mainly comedy but i want to
just a couple of real fights on the card
as well what is an mna mma round three
three minutes five
three five minute rounds
it's a lot of cardio don't look at me
i'm not going to get you ready all right
no no i went to a fight with uh tito
ortiz yeah back in the day in san diego
as an older guy his last one of his last
fights
and both of those dudes were almost
going like this
oh you're talking about chuck liddell
one of them where they it was like the
rubber flat but it was like 20 years
after the last time they were yeah yeah
it's
i mean your legs go
and
and those guys were ex they were
exhausted but they were beating they
were beating five minutes doesn't seem
like a lot
well that's the other thing when you get
older it's just the way it is when you
get older you get tired faster angelo
dundee told me that when you that when a
fighter turned 30
for his birthday your legs go some
fighters have legs longer they go 29
you're like
and 30 you're like
because everything's derived from the
everything but then there's take like uh
what is it um
who beat like the heavyweight guy that
yeah foreman was old and out of shape
but he had
technique and strategy and like wore
people out without doing that much
physical
like action it was like a we beat people
he became the champion when he was like
i don't know how he's like in his 40s
maybe he was big almost but did you see
the punch he hit michael moore that was
that's the fire you see that little head
that little short little jab that dude
was out he's they got hit by like
[ __ ] a semi he got hit a lot in that
fight and he hit him with that short
little punch and he went down and he
thought about getting up and he just
laid back down and that thing because of
who he is and how he knew how to throw
it george foreman had some of the
biggest hands i've ever sha i shook his
hand it was a big fat puffy but yeah he
was an animal salt or just normal hand
size no no big yeah big heads okay
assault does that too
the uh um uh tony what injuries have you
had what injuries have you had oh uh
honestly but do people do people that
are fans of yours and people around the
world do they know
your injuries or are you one of those
people that
would just keep it to you almost keep it
to yourself um some of mine have been
significant enough that they've sort of
made news so yeah there's those that
people know about but i don't really i
don't
promote it or blast it out there this is
how much he doesn't promote it he got a
movie just came out documentary
till the wheels fall off yeah
i watched it and i've been skating with
him my whole life and i did not know
that he'd been hurt
that much i did not that's always a
great sign of a good doctor my 22 year
old grandson was so stoked when he found
out that you were going to be on the
show today
and
also it's the first time somebody in
their 70s has you stoked in the proper
context
that's a good point well go ahead one of
these days i'll make him happy really
he he was so stoked that i was coming
down here and i said you know he said no
about him he says papa that guy's broken
almost every bone in his body he says i
use video games he says i was stuck on
video games
i used to hate for him to be on the
skateboard because he's playing football
and i'm saying you're going to break
bones you're not going to be out there
you're jacking up at school but
he was so stoked because you were going
to be here but he knows about you oh
thank you injuries no my injury yeah
well i guess so
you don't have to you don't have to say
you're up there i don't care but if
people knieva was alive today who would
win in a foot racing him
because he broke everybody
i
met him when he was older he wasn't
moving very well he would know if he was
not um he'd win but i did i've had a lot
of concussions like him unfortunately um
and uh
let's see i broke my
elbow i broke my pelvis i broke my femur
two months ago
um still coming back from that one uh
separated my shoulder
two knee surgery on this knee one knee
surgery on this knee one was
both cartilage
other than that my ankles just are just
loose yeah like i never broke them but
they roll really easily it's almost like
i would have benefited from breaking
them yeah at the time
and rolling the ankles just
it's nice
and
yeah that's why i gave up that is
literally why i gave up street skating
because of yeah yeah yeah i rolled my
ankle super bad on two or one time i had
it all taped up
we went
just shooting like messing around
downtown in between
our uh tour stops yeah went down these
little three stairs rolled the other one
just as bad
and then i'm on tour with both my ankles
taped up so they can't move and i was
like this is a sign that i don't i
should not street skate anymore do you
guys that skate do they tape their
ankles guys like speak competitively no
they don't cause you you can't have that
you have to be able to have it but move
well but what we do we we we mostly
skate ramps which is like radius
when we fall we knee slide down right
the ram when you're street skating you
just got to run out of everything you
got to you got to take the impact and
when you grow up skating how we do
you don't you don't know how to do that
right you just don't have that way of
falling yeah we full bad but i think the
the but the benefits of skating lasting
as long as it has is that it has
shown kids that are starting to skate
how
to prepare yourself or how not to be
injured or maybe you like looking back
on the history of something you could
say well i'm i got to be prepared that
this might happen or that might happen
where you guys were innovators
that that was maybe and our equipment
was really shitty so like our
i mean the first time i got knocked out
is just because all i was wearing was
plastic on my head
with some foam around it because that's
all we had that's all they knew
nowadays
you know the the helmets are
of the standard that they'll save your
life like my helmet has saved my life
for sure wow
when uh you know now kids now kids um
wear helmets when they ride bikes
cut to maybe 1973.
my grandmother
bought me a schwinn bike
and the guy recommended that
i get a helmet and my grandmother said
well that's two gifts so pick the
[ __ ] bike or pick the helmet wow
because that's two things yeah
and the bike had two tournaments i'm
surprised she didn't think i remember
i remember right now i can tell you i
was at peddler's west in san fernando i
was at the cash register she looked down
at me and she goes that's two gifts so
if you want the bike or you want the
helmet
i'm going to take the bike yeah
and of course i've hit my [ __ ] head
all over all over the place man you know
how did it break i went to the doctor
how'd you break your nose i said i don't
remember but
the
now they're all prepared or have
injuries and stuff like that and just
where i mean did you go i don't think we
even thought about hitting our heads
maybe if you fell off a skateboard or
writing a book in our day especially
you're talking about 70s you've just
said oh you rang your bell
you know that was it it was like all
right get back out there yeah
yeah we had no idea
they didn't come up until 70s and 80s
i had a harley and i was riding my heart
without a helmet
what about the first skateboards that
came out that you could buy
uh with the with the metal wheels
that
um remember those that were just i'm not
designing we got we were luckily we
missed that era let me look at it right
after that have you had a skateboard and
you and your friends went down that
metal wheels and they were about that
thin yeah and you went down roller
skates
they were the ones that roller skates
you went down a hill
that was remotely long and you didn't
fall your [ __ ] would vibrate for
maybe 10 days afterwards
that's what you just felt
but but in the i was around when they
went to the urethane wheel and just
everything
to me everything changed when they when
you went to the euro thing that was i
mean i was lucky that i got into skating
right at that era yeah because had i
if i had to ride metal or clay wheels i
don't think i would have made it through
or or i've been that interested in it
they were clay wheels too that's right
the kind of pink reddish salmon color
ones
the steel wheels used to come i remember
as i can remember that the old steel
skates that you'd screw onto your shoes
they would just take those wheels off
and put them on a piece of wood those
are the original skateboards yep
gentlemen it is all about confidence
when it's time for sex right sometimes
stress anxiety a bad day just the state
of the world out there right now all
that stuff can affect your performance
can get in your head to ruin the fun for
all of you thankfully bluechew.com is
here and they're coming to the rescue if
you haven't heard of it bluechu is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable form and this is
one of the best parts at a fraction of
the cost bluetooth tablets help men
achieve harder and stronger erections
and combats all forms of ed because
bluetooth is an online prescription
service there are no visits to the
doctor's office none of that awkward
conversation stuff no awkward waiting in
line at the pharmacy and it ships right
to your door in a discreet package no
one's gonna know what's coming to you
they just think it's your latest amazon
box it's a beautiful thing the process
is simple you just sign up at
bluechew.com you consult briefly with
one of their licensed medical providers
and then once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
best part it is all done online you
don't even have to leave the house
you know sex should be the best part of
your day when you get to have it that is
uh and we don't want you we don't want
that to get ruined by getting in your
head anything that's going on in your
life anything on your mind stuff like
that so the chewables from bluechew.com
can really help and make sure that
you're able to perform at your best
every time that you get the opportunity
to have a little fun out there so here's
a special deal for our listeners try
blue chew free when you use our promo
code omghi
at checkout and you just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code omghi to receive your first
month free
who who's the biggest innovator of like
skating equipment from back of the new i
think but but for equipment yeah back in
that when you when you went like what
were the names that they would say like
hey you gotta you gotta get
oh the the brand names yeah oh man well
we were just talking about when urethane
wheels started you road writer fours was
that was the rolls rolls-royce yeah uh
no one could get them in fact i just
bought a set on ebay
that were slightly used for a thousand
bucks wow
that's how that's how sought after they
were back in the day but um through the
years
i mean you could probably help me kevin
but it would it would have been in our
area would have been sims
gns
logan or ski
bane my first skateboard was a bane
those were the the og's and then through
the 80s the the big names were
powell vision
sims santa cruz
genes it was protect the pads
uh rector
oh yeah oh wow rector pads so if you if
you had rector pads
you were in it
you were the most safe
yeah but but also just it was like you
were johnny come lately you know you
were it was it was christmas morning
they get rector pads
mad rat shorts
neon gloves
it's like it's like going when you go
shopping for for back to school clothes
it's the only time you look that [ __ ]
neat the whole year yeah yeah yeah
were they considered sissies because
they had all the all the stuff with them
you had to wear that to go to skate park
back then
so it wasn't really an issue it was it
was more like are you gonna go to skate
the pool or not
right cause they're not gonna let you in
otherwise
it was a good idea who went in the pool
first i mean that's [ __ ] brilliant
the dogtown z-boys yep [ __ ] brilliant
the idea of that that somebody saw an
empty pool and said well let's go in
there with the skateboards
yeah they were surfers i mean i think
that was a surface at heart so they saw
it as a wave
and then when i started skating that was
already established
and
i thought it was the coolest thing ever
those guys were flying they were flying
you know and and the other guys that
were skating were just doing 360s and
pirouettes and dancing and i was like
nah
i wanna do that right
so so you grew up in uh you were in
carlsbad san diego in san diego yeah i
think uh well tyra santa my my dad was
in the navy yeah and then he was
stationed there so did you move around
because your dad was in the navy or were
you no i got lucky that i was the
youngest of four kids so he
finally uh ended his naval career in san
diego but all my brothers and sisters my
brother my sisters had to move all
around so so so did you play did you
guys play did you play baseball or
football when growing up yeah did you in
australia you mean
cricket yeah we're gonna explain quicker
to me later on uh i don't really get it
it's outta time
so that the crowd can drink and not be
home with their wives
i always felt like that was the bring
that game over here
[Laughter]
so so
and your thing you had did you would you
consider yourself is it hyperactive
were you yeah yeah
were you did you take any medicine for
that or no i mean
i feel like it was just the general
diagnosis for kids my age right now
yeah latch key kids it's just like i
don't know he's too he's always wants to
do something so a latchkey kid do you
know where alaska kid is yeah uh
somebody that that's when somebody get
home nobody's home yeah both parents
working and they leave a door open and
then you come to the window yeah so um
um
there used to be a commercial even about
last year kids and they don't even i
mean it's criminal i think now that if
you get home and nobody's home and your
kids are and you you get no parent
around they'd be like uh i think that
kid's been abandoned like no my parents
are just out but now you can't leave
yeah i mean like from age
eight or nine yeah
walking home from school and just
go home and the doors the side doors
open go to the windows watch them leave
it to beaver and that's right bugs money
and like just that was it where the [ __ ]
did what the [ __ ] happened to kids where
you can't leave a kid alone or you can't
go home by himself and not and not freak
out that his parents aren't there with a
snack
or or you know some comforting words
it's a difference out there watching the
difference
[Laughter]
family's gone the kids are there yeah
looking at porno i i think that um
you can benefit a kid from having both
parents but also i think you can you can
hurt a kid by having both parents if
your parents are what they would
consider helicopter parents or they do
everything for you fine
it's a fine line yeah because you want
them to be able to be
self-sufficient but they're not
i
yeah my wife and i have that
conversation all the time where it's
like remember you had to go to the bank
like you had to go to the bank with your
mom
and wait in that line and there was no
choi you had no
no one's offering to do something else
with you or
play dates and stuff like that it was
just like play listen
play days where they call
your friend your your parent will call
your friend's house
and then they'll say
can gail play saturday afternoon
and they'll be like sure and then your
mom will set you up with a play date
with that kid i [ __ ] like that kid
yes
exactly and then our ours was like if
the if the garage door was open your
friend was home yeah or all the bikes
were on the line all the bikes yeah yeah
exactly i was one of seven kids and
nobody gave a [ __ ] about a playdate
you know hey yeah dark come home
daylight you're gone yep
i mean my dad i remember i remember like
hey can can my friend spend the night
he's like i don't care
every time that's what it was yeah
like [ __ ] do what you want it's your
room i don't care go
so your dad was in the military was he
like uh the dad was he a hard ass or
what the good news he see to everyone
else he seemed like a hard ass but he
was pretty soft yeah you know but he but
he definitely came off his gruff and and
rub people the wrong way yeah that's
cool
i didn't have a dad but you want a dad
that would say hey hey [ __ ] you
don't worry about it come on let's go
that had your back yeah it was kind of
like that but but but but to a point
where it was invasive
yeah where he would he would sort of
fight these bat like my battles and then
i would just be like oh man now it's
worse
you know what it's true
that we fought our own battles and there
made you fight your own battles but now
if your parent fights your battle for
you like tony just said
it's they make it worse it's not a good
look nobody fought my battles and i made
sure
that we didn't interfere i was cognizant
and not interfere with my kids battles
you know
i can remember my mom grabbing me saying
no pendejo get out there you did it go
and they had to learn how to fight their
own uh these two guys were fighting the
guys i grew up with
kind of guys in the neighborhood you
like and you didn't like
and
they were fighting and the dad came home
as they were fighting and they kept
fighting
nobody stopped fighting so all the boy
friends are in the front yard and these
two dudes are fighting they got each
other headlock like this and the kids
upside down turn each other around [ __ ]
punching them and [ __ ] the dad gets home
and he looks at him and you know we're
all looking down and we go no let him
fight the deaths and let him fight
and then i think the dude was upside
down and he was like having a little
like spit bubbles coming
like he's losing consciousness
and his dad goes you want to go to
mcdonald's and he goes come on [ __ ]
kick in there
i'll take kick his ass and i'll take it
to mcdonald's that was like his uh the
corner man telling you to
you know
he choked them out and he just like went
limp and then the guy get took off and
other guys are patting him on the back
leading that guy limp like that did he
go to mcdonald's
forget about mcdonald's he went and
slammed the door on him
but i mean it's beautiful man you
couldn't get that [ __ ]
he came home and we backed up we didn't
even run we just backed up he goes no no
let him fight and then he flipped them
over and i mean and now you know kids
will never fight they'll never
you know excuse me never never killing
an animal by accident or you know
they'll never break a window they'll
never throw a rock
well they still do that yeah do they
yeah
i got a 13 year old
yeah they
they're still subversive yeah but
everyone's on you know
everyone's got cameras so yeah it's hard
you know the do somebody's do you agree
with when when they look back at this
time in our lives and they'll say what
was the single most destructive
thing of this the last couple
generations they say it will be the
internet
that that's the most destructive thing
to mankind or humankind because it took
away the conversation that people would
have sure it took away in fact
it yeah it took away the [ __ ] it's on
the tip of my tongue who's that [ __ ]
dude
and then the guy next to you is like you
know sure
it took away the whole conversation
where everybody now thinks they know
everything or can report things
if somebody um you know
take is drunk
i fell asleep in a casino about you know
maybe 10 years ago i remember that and
uh i was like i was [ __ ] up and then
when the police got me i said what are
they how did all these cops get in my
room
um but i was lit up man i was [ __ ] up
i was in canada at the
palace
over the other side of detroit
and you and do you want nobody knows why
i drank maybe
23 shots of
patron
i just got divorced and i had the day
before i had breakfast with my business
manager and he told me how much i had to
pay
my ex-wife and
yeah the next day i was flying i started
drinking on the plane
and it didn't stop after and
man
they sold even though i
you know i didn't get arrested they
thought i got arrested and but you said
it was because of the age of social
media that yeah caused that so yeah yeah
i don't remember getting up or falling i
remember where i was but it's about that
i was sitting down drinking and when i
got up
did you go to sleep no i just fell down
oh so you were just lying there for a
second
because the cops came from the hotel
and then they called the police
and i didn't get arrested for public
drunkenness the cop took me to
the hospital to emergency for whatever
because i fell and i told him i heard i
don't remember i told him
and then the cop waited for me it's in
canada by the way yeah you know they
have more yeah the cop he didn't shoot
me he waited for me
and was a mountain was he on a horse no
he wasn't
that would have been awesome uh and then
he dropped me off at the hotel and he
said before he left he said can i take a
selfie with you
so i'm hammered and he there's an
officer and we took a selfie and then i
wandered back up to the 35th floor so it
just made news it was just made news the
next day i was on in tmz
and then my publicist called and said
hey uh you want to tell me what happened
last night i said what do you mean
have you seen tmz and i said no and then
i'm so i can
you know
i thought it was cool i got up i said
hey i fell asleep in the casinos now i
fell asleep at home depot or
yeah
it was where they were serving
free alcohol right yeah you got that
but i think you're right i think you
know the camera and the video and you
you know you if somebody's videotaping
you without your consent what other
what's the law of somebody's videotaping
that you can send if you have an
argument with your wife
in the parking lot and then someone
comes up to me dude they're doing this
what what's what i don't know what the
law is i dealt with murders i didn't
deal with it but that's going to
potentially be a murder maybe
[Laughter]
don't you want to prevent murder
can i only talk to you about [ __ ] that
happens after people died
[Music]
i know i can't record you without your
consent you know
a voice record or something like that
yeah you you have to know it in order
for me to be able to use it what's more
dangerous i don't know that out in the
public
it's against the law to take a video of
anybody
it's not yeah yeah i don't exactly
so that guy could go around you guys and
just say hey man don't videotape me
and he could he's i'm going to say too
bad i'm in public yeah no expectations i
don't think there is uh
any violation there
yeah they do it all the time when
karen's flip out at starbucks
the person films she goes you know i
don't approve of your
videoing and the guy goes stiff [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love watching karen's yeah
[Laughter]
is when the cops talk to you and you're
in a public area of videoing
you don't have to answer any questions
and now because that's the internet has
shown everyone that oh yeah so people
with less of an education will do that
or they're like can i you know i see
some identification and the person will
not answer them
it's like
can i see some identification
i don't answer questions
and it's like oh you're that guy huh
it turns it looks most of the videos i
watch the officer leaves it seems like
if you're in the right spot you have to
answer or can you say i want a lawyer no
you you're
right they're here you have to be
suspected of a crime get out of that car
you don't have to be
on a just a regular traffic stop yeah
you have to ask for identification you
have to answer the question they don't
you can hook them right out of the car
is it different states because
i can only i can only say what happens
here people don't like what's hard
on that yeah
i'm like here's my id what the [ __ ] i
wouldn't do why are we doing the big
thing on the internet right now is
people claiming they don't have to do
[ __ ] because they're not
uh citizens of the united states they're
sovereign citizens is that yeah i've
heard about that sovereign citizens you
know you don't have to you don't have to
what are they part of royal family or
something they just think you don't you
know have to obey the laws those laws
are for other people not for them
they're so and every one of them that i
see like that ends up getting hooked up
yeah they they all end up getting that
makes sense you know how how do you get
away saying
i'm the duke of public drunkenness
that's a hard flex that's on a cop
you know when i was in high school lapd
over their foothill division they're the
ones that
beat rodney king they were uh allegedly
i'd probably have to say sorry
no i was alleged okay so i grew up and
we used to go up in that area and play
golfing and play baseball area and that
area was the police department for where
i grew where i grew up and at a high
school game
the police wanted this area cleared out
and i happened to be walking through at
the time that the cops had cleared this
area out
and he pushed me from behind
and he's a man i'm probably like 17 and
he police officer he pushed me from
behind
and those guys were like hey man [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] you and i think he could
have killed me i think he got he might
have been able to i almost broke my neck
because i wasn't prepared to be pushed
from behind yeah and when he pushed me
it it snapped it kind of went back and i
blacked out and yeah we call that a
chicken neck
that's an injury and skateboarding that
we get a lot uh yeah from not not from
from a cop but yeah from our own our own
mistakes and i wasn't prepared for it so
you could have said you were you were a
skateboarder you've got chicken neck how
long do you think the statue limited can
i go back there now and say that
i've been able to perform sorry
you're seventeen so that was like 20
years ago yeah 20 years
yeah uh what is there any question that
your nephew wanted to ask do you want to
ask someone or no
my grant no he just he was just he was
awestruck he was i'm telling you he was
totally stoked that i was going to be
able to come down here and
meet with you have be on the show with
you today and he just kept saying that's
awesome papa that's that's that's cool
he should have brought him over
and i thought all the time
the the free i asked him i said do you
think he knows rob deer dick because
we're hooked on uh
a ridiculousness yes i love the show
and i said he was on that order
no he said do you think he knows rob
dude you you know that's like asking
continue to talk let me think of a good
one think of a good one rob deer dick is
also
one of the top 10 noted skateboarders
all right yeah
i'm not going to say anything now no no
no no no no seriously asking tony hawk
if he knows rob dirk is like asking
um
i didn't know elvis presley
was the singer at the hilton hotel just
just no it's not anything no it's not no
i don't know just to clarify things i
didn't ask him if he knew him i asked my
grandson i take it easy
they knew each other for a cop you saw a
motion oh maybe not a big big chicken i
mean they're two of the most famous
skateboarders in the world
is rob was one of the best skateboarders
he's one of the most famous
he was really good
at his peak yeah um which was more like
90s
he was a legit pro for sure and and
always did really unique video stuff in
in skate videos so he was like part
personality and part skating and that's
how he emerged into doing this yeah and
i've never seen him skating he just
mentions
the fact yeah he was a decent press
skater and so i asked since i'm
watched
as a family we watch ridiculousness not
for his skateboarding ability but just
because it's a it's a funny show yeah
and so i asked do you think he knows him
and he says probably they were all
skateboarders you know i imagine they
met each other one time or two yeah well
and also through those years especially
when when rob was coming up skating was
very
small it was a you know it was it was in
a lull of popularity the industry was
very small there's only a handful of
skate companies so you know everybody
at at what point so so in reading about
you like the skateboard to you or the
skateboard for you was
which is what what's beautiful about
having something that you could
like it became your outlet right it
became an escape
for you to be oh yeah skateboard and
just be away right yeah um
i don't know i i i never felt like i
really fit into team sports i enjoyed
baseball and basketball but i didn't i
didn't excel i was okay i was really
really small and then when i found
skating it was like oh i can do this at
my own pace
i don't have to listen to a coach that's
what i'm saying and and there is a
community and and the community seemed
really cool it was they were all misfits
and crazy you know punk rock music and
so it was more like oh this is this is
where i belong do you think that they're
misfits like or are they just people
that
are kind of cool hanging together like
you know you know eventually i think in
clicks of kids it's like you know my
daughter when we went to high school
there's a click of girls but and then
you get heartbroken because those girls
don't include you in the things but it's
like when you see who they are i mean do
you really want to be around girls it's
different now it's more popular to get
into skateboarding when he started
skateboarding it was not a it wasn't a
brag at all it was it'd be like why why
would you do that yeah i was immediately
when i when i chose skating and and
dropped the other sports i was
outcast at school
that was the furthest thing from cool
you could do is skating and then when i
was skating which was
kind of ironic i was so skinny and i did
it in this weird style
that i became an outcast in
skateboarding and i was like
he was wow it was yeah but but i had
enough
in fact my friend kevin who's right over
here he and i've been skating together
since we were 12 years old and um he and
i
would bounce the tricks off each other
and we kind of had our own thing and our
own crew so that was enough right
i think that's all it's awesome man yeah
my grandson had to have a
the special shoes the the athletic i'm
assuming that you're wearing a
skateboarder yeah well that's what tommy
awkward
oh that's cool yeah he did he had to
have the right ones well for in our day
we had to have vans
i remember my first pair of vans
like uh
10 years old my dad brought him home
you know drove me to the van store i had
to pick him out
got the box and i was just like yeah
like checking that i kept checking the
friction on everything every surface
is that what events were created for for
skateboarding
um
yes and no i think that they found that
they were really good for skateboarding
and then vans just leaned into it
yeah and said yeah we're a skate shoe
they still haven't got a better one
amazing right still the best skates here
there was a band store in granada hills
and it was a titan look at that i mean
look under seats and i mean
and you know white dudes wore vans and
uh
that store that store is still open man
it stayed open and you think this little
store
with the skateboard in the name and you
think this place got to be closed i was
over there and i was driving around and
i said oh [ __ ] it's still open and
thriving now i mean yeah truly oh yeah
yeah i don't know who owns bands but or
when it probably started i mean that was
a big shift in skateboarding too
especially in the last
15 years 20 years is that it was
considered white boy sport right and
suddenly it was everywhere right and
everyone was welcomed and it got really
diverse very quickly and uh it's awesome
and then you do you remember what the
first tricks that you guys started to do
that you guys thought you could do like
and and still and still stand up after
the
thing is done like i'm gonna do this
mine were more
technical stuff like turning my board
yeah and doing tricks on the coping
right not not big aerials because i when
i first started i just didn't have the
the build to to get the speed so i just
learned all these little they used to
call them circus tricks right they're
like oh he does stuff like he's throwing
a baton in the air
and that's all i had so the first trick
i ever
invented was called a backside varial
it's basically you reach you reach
grab your board and turn it a half a
turn under your legs yeah and
it didn't it didn't move the needle
but i was hyped that i made something up
right
tell me about what happened that trick's
like a part of
[ __ ] somebody skateboard tricks now
and he was the first person to do it
pretty impressive man what about the 900
that they i read where you tried so many
times yeah that one i chased for
over 10 years that's what said yeah um i
did uh
mike mcgill did the first mctwist which
was a 540 in 1984
and then the next year i learned 720
which is double spin
and then kind of
dabbled try 900s right after that
and it was just too scary it was i
landed on my back a couple times and
then i like once in a while i would go
back to it and then around 1995 i
started getting serious about it and i
started spinning a lot he was trying him
too man um didn't work out
but
the commitment it takes and the risk
factor
are so huge that it's like you try it
for a half hour and you're done for
a couple weeks
so i would just keep coming back to it
and then finally figured it out in 1999
at the x game at the x games yeah i got
close before that
actually landed one and then fell into
the bottom of the ramp broke my rib
um
in 1994
i did that
and then didn't commit to it again until
five years later and they said he broke
some teeth from doing amazing i broke my
teeth doing all kinds of other stuff
i need to replace five times oh wow
what'd you break your teeth when it
wasn't skateboarding
oh no it's the other tricks okay okay
amazing oh uh let's see uh 50 um
what else did i bring my teeth on
i tried to do ollie varial back then
like shove it in the air
are you not getting your hands 360 very
vacay what's that i wasn't getting my
hands out yeah
because you were doing stuff in concrete
so it's grippy concrete all right yeah i
lost my teeth in the in the del mar hot
pipe concrete wow woke up in the
ambulance without my teeth
oh
bored
that's some tough guys
it's weird because it's not tough yeah
that's the thing is that like it's not
something that i like to brag about it's
not i don't enjoy that aspect of it or
trying to promote that it's just it just
it does happen
and for what we do if you're gonna make
a crew out of it it's probably gonna
happen
um but also this would probably be at
some at some point guys would say you
know what i'm gonna [ __ ] this man like a
lot of people did this yeah i think a
lot of people did you ever go to a
mouthpiece after that if you lost some
teeth
no
my
my mom wanted me to when i first lost
them because it's expensive buying new
teeth
but if you think that you were shunned
for being skateboard show up with a
mouse mouthpiece
skateboarder i think you can't do that
they're like well it's a it's a honor to
you know it's an honor to lose teeth and
put them back again and again if that's
was he and i were doing a little
like a doubles routine where we we have
choreography or whatever and
and one of us missed a queue and um
which one
yeah i wonder
okay yeah he went a little he i was
supposed to go under him and he wasn't
going quite high enough and he landed on
me and when he hit my the top of my head
my teeth went down and one tooth just
went oh
god it's all right
thanks kevin we made it through it's all
right
what brought you what brought you to uh
to the united states from australia to
be a skateboarder yeah yeah i moved here
when i was well i didn't move here i
came here when i was 17. like as soon as
i was old enough to
that my parents couldn't you wanted to
compete so you were good enough to say
i'm going to the united states to
compete like something no wow because i
knew i'd seen these guys and there was
videos and a couple of times they came
to australia and did demon demos so we
got to see it and i was like i'm not far
off
and i feel like the next step is you go
to america and you
watch these guys and you move up and
then you turn i was the first australian
to ever turn pro from i think that's
awesome so it was more of a i wasn't
really sure but it was i didn't care i
didn't really have a plan i was more
i want to be a skateboarder
and america has the skateboarders that i
look up to so i just want to skate with
them what was the skateboarding scene in
australia
it was it was pretty good because it was
the next time around he's been through
more waves than me but when i got into
his early 80s where it was just starting
to come back again and he was the star
of the show pretty much the first time
first i went to australia it felt like
we were led zeppelin going to see a
foreign country for the first time
what so i think that hype being around
that and i you know and then watching
their videos i was like oh i know what i
want to be when i grow up like
undoubtedly i know what i want to be
so when i went there i just went in
amateur contest my idea was because it's
different era but you win an amateur
contest and then you can turn pro right
so i won an amateur contest and i turned
pro and that was on the tail end of it
was it was the beginning of
skateboarding's end that was about to be
incredibly uh unpopular and there was no
more money in it and being a ramp
skateboarder was the uh extra uncool
that was the most
unpopular skating was such a big thing
so when i turned pro i was like top five
in the world i got fifth in the world
cup and they were like
we can't even pay you i'm like okay i
guess so you got the title
yeah but there wasn't too it wasn't a
place not much to it yeah yeah there
wasn't back to the show
supermarket yeah oh wow man
and then i came back three
maybe four times i think the fourth time
i came here for six months because back
then you could get a holiday visa for
six months so i just stayed and lived on
people's couches and people bought me
food and all that kind of stuff just
other skateboarders taking care of me
and then
i think the fourth time is when
i got sponsored with a paycheck yeah
like 700 a month i think it was from
element
and that was i'd made it i didn't need
it it's almost like being an independent
band and then a label saying you know
here's seven hundred dollars and keep
you know use our stuff and and and fly
you around to all the that was the most
important part is every contest
everywhere they flew me to it so i was
living the life
and in that skateboard world
do skateboarders get along with each
other or would you say it's like comedy
where every comedian hates each other i
just started doing stand-up for the last
couple years and you guys are way
bitchier than we are totally
you guys are so [ __ ] catty because
they become successful who would hate
somebody
became because they became successful
yeah i mean when i started like you guys
there was probably
three latino comedians it was angel
salazar paul rodriguez there was
me 1979.
and after what at 42 years i've had some
success to those dudes i'm like a
sellout a punks of a queer you're like
oh that dude made it man it's like there
is some respect that has to be shown to
somebody who has been doing something
for a long time and you would say hey
man respect to you for taking the
journey and opening up you know avenues
that we didn't have before you came
along silence i mean it's i think it was
a lot cattier
in his era where it was more it wasn't
even about the success it was more just
the
it was just the peanut gallery of like
oh his leaners suck right yeah but but
it was
but it was like
some of it was ingest two so it was
everyone was fair game
yeah right and even if you're successful
yeah you're successful and
and you're winning but but
there could be no cries of sellout
because there was nothing
yeah nobody nobody came
one guy's way better and that's that's
how can you hate on that he's the first
though the first pro event i ever uh
entered was a hundred dollars for first
place
uh 75 second 50 for third i got fourth
but how much is that
zero nice pat on the back just make sure
where was it where was that uh whittier
skate city
right here california yeah yeah yeah in
east l.a yeah no no what are your
delivery right we're out skate city used
to be right there at washington what is
it now mexican market uh no they closed
down
they closed uh just within the last four
or five years they closed it down
i don't know what it is now yeah i mean
i was amazing man the the main parks
back then southern california uh i live
in san diego so my dad would drive me to
uh whittier pomona
lakewood
uh resida
upland and
uh
and big o was orange county and then
back then how would you hear about
events that were coming out that that
because you didn't have you know would
they be in the paper or would they be
just the word of mouth of the guys
it was it was such a small industry
everyone knew
they'd you know whittier that that was
called the turkey shoot like with your
turkey shoot every
everyone knew because because your
sponsor would call you
or i mean they had their i don't even
know if there was a skate magazine then
you just everyone found out and then
back up pomona does it called the
skateboarder shoot that's a tough
pomona pipe and pool was it was a sick
park really good yeah yeah and skate
park started showing up around around
one of the 90s
the skate parks yeah that was 80s mid
80s
but then there's the second wave yes and
then they they all closed by by
89 they were all gone i came here
to skate these legendary skate parks i
saw on video and alpine had been uh
partially demolish it was over but there
was a little bit left and somebody drove
me there with my other australian friend
and we skated the one section in the
corner that wasn't bulldozed and we
found a piece of tile and just so they
could say let's get it upland yeah it
was not legendary in skate circles it
was huge
and it just how did the wave end how
does it end and how does it start again
uh it ended mostly because skating was
going through these cycles of popularity
and fad so it kind of reached the end of
that and liability liability for skate
parks was just impossible
right liability insurance was impossible
to get
parks won't do enough business to
justify it anyway so they all just shut
down and then skaters took to the
streets yep and then even though it
wasn't popular it went through a whole
revolution of style and tricks and
people learned how to skate handrails
and right ledges and jumping stairs and
then it was like came back around
95 96 first x games
and then kids were all about it because
they're like look at these guys oh
they're you know and they could do it
anywhere yeah
when i was a teenager we had we had
skateboards and we would go down this
this little incline there in mission
hills by brandt park
my buddies with skateboard understeer
wheels
um
at first and then into some urethane
stuff and but but
i had a house in hawaii and they had
just black topped the the street it was
a long street and i had a kind of
downward climb
and i was in my late 40s and i said to
my daughter i said we landed in maui and
then we would think that we would take
the ferry over to lanai had a house on
the night and i said to her and my wife
was married at the time i said we're
gonna go we're gonna go into this skate
shop right here and i'm gonna buy a
couple of skateboarders and my wife is
i'm in my 40s late 40s she goes for what
i said to skateboard that blacktop
road in front of the concert amazing in
front of the house and she goes
[ __ ] i said no seriously like i love
skateboarding when i was growing up
so i bought a little wider board with a
little bit of tape you know that keeps
your footing on it bought my own one and
barefooted in shorts with a white
t-shirt i went down that thing and i was
standing there and it was like this and
sweet nothing made me happier man oh you
did it you hold it everything was okay
okay why don't we we are waiting for the
big screen
pete rose
that's usually how the story goes you've
heard it many times let me let me end it
so my daughter was had not skateboarded
and
she fell and kicked the board out and he
hit me on the side of my ankle the doggy
bite and he dropped me yeah and i said
why did you kick the board out she goes
i didn't kick the boards you know what
it was but she did and then i decided to
do it without her so i wouldn't tell him
when i would do it but i [ __ ] loved
it man that's a long-ass street and i
would not even a street in front of
thing and i would just go like back and
forth
i didn't do this [ __ ] i just went but it
just the the the air through there and
then i'll do it late at night or in the
morning oh man it was it was off it was
awesome i never got to a skate park
but
that's enough i loved it man yeah i
loved it as long as you're having fun
man it doesn't it was no matter what one
you're doing you know i lost in the
divorce but i'm gonna get another
i'm going to get a i'll get another
skipper i love i loved it man i mean i
you know i remember
you could you could pave another
driveway pretty much anywhere it doesn't
have to be in lanai i've never heard
decided to you that she loved it but i
live up there in los well i live up
there in los angeles
and there's
streets that go down but they're they're
too steep for a 62-year-old man what's
that one street that
in the morning i think i would
mulholland no i don't know but going
down i would there is a street that
people bombing home baxter baxter street
oh okay
i would go down with the
levels oh yeah
yeah i don't think is there a 62 year
old guy out of the skate tour no
probably not we're coming really good
yeah we're leading the charge yeah here
we go
just got a few more years
but at what age does all those things
start affecting i wasn't really paying
attention was it in the late 30s that we
woke up and after doing something that
we used to love to do as a kid and then
you realize oh [ __ ]
i can't move is it i've been fighting
that off for a long time i would say it
was in my late 40s when i started to
realize my limitations a little more
where it was like all right that trick's
just not going to happen again
you know that that motion or that i just
can't get into that yeah but then i kept
fighting it and then
broke my leg uh two months ago and and
where were you when you broke tony what
was i doing yeah big twist
it was a silly one yeah i didn't have
enough speed it was like i was taking
chances it was stupid oh yeah
did you know you didn't have enough
speed yeah yeah i watched him everyone
knew everyone knew him
you can throw things down which is part
of the fun
sometimes like if things don't feel
right and you make an adjustment and you
kind of i don't know how to put it but
you know what it's like sack up you know
you're like
like it is what it is i'm still going to
go if you can save it and i've saved it
many many times but i i pushed it i
pushed my luck too far
and i do you remember did you remember
the pain
i remember i remember falling strangely
i kind of like i wasn't quite standing
up when i came down the wall and i was i
was half squad and then all of a sudden
my leg was behind me and all of a sudden
i could feel it
detached like immediately
i was sliding to a stop and and i looked
up and i was like it was pointed the
other way for a second yeah
so when he rolled over i saw him
straighten it which made me realize that
before that it was pointing another way
so i thought he blew his knee out
because i've done the same thing and i
was like oh he blew his mcl out and then
when the medics came they cut his shorts
and he had
a hole and i'm like yeah compound it's a
compound fraction oh lord yeah
if you're gonna do it do it big
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] wow man that's incredible man
that's but he's back man we skated
yesterday
i wouldn't say i'm back i'm i'm i'm
getting back on the ramp but uh my
strength is very weak
but you're going to be already back it's
listen man i'm telling you it's amazing
in a time
when most people are [ __ ] and they
just don't dig in like you know when you
when when the fact that you gave kids
trophies for just signing up to a league
you destroyed the competitive nature in
a in a kid like
when i was when i was six seven years
old
six years old i signed up for little
league and i had a
a problem already with emotion like i
told my
coach to go [ __ ] himself i was seven
and i was on a team that never lost a
game and they they sent me down to to
like with the farm league which would be
just the worst team of the league and
that other team i had to watch win every
game and then win a championship and as
long as much as i love baseball up until
i played in sunday leagues in la after
high school about 20. never won a
championship went down to the last pitch
never won a championship i always
thought it was because
i got punished for not
being having a better attitude as a kid
and i never
won a trophy or never won a championship
and when you start giving kids
trophies for participation
what drove me and what really helped me
later on in life was the fact that i
would always lose and save next year
we're going to come back we're going to
be better and without the incentive of
wanting to either
be better or
accomplish something yourself but when
you're going to give somebody a trophy
there's really no incentive to dig in
and it's about digging in it's about
when
when somebody says you can't do it and
you don't even need to tell them i'm
gonna do it you just you just it just
turns on in here yeah and when kids lose
that or not have it it's for life
you can get it i mean my
my kid grew up in that but he has me
so he's seen that
yeah you could just fart it away and get
a trophy and no one would care but if
you really want to do something in life
you got to put in work
and he
grew up in this [ __ ] mentality world
but he isn't that's why he's he works
you know he's skateboards now and it's
skateboarding
that'll teach you it really will yeah
yeah but we're not you're not going to
celebrate mediocrity and skateboarding
i'll tell you that i think i think it's
just a great thing for somebody to have
because it's like a key that you turn on
the lights going to go you can use it
for the rest of your life in all these
other facets because if you get hurt
trying to do something in a parking lot
by yourself
and then you try it again and you get
hurt and so on and so forth for a
considerable amount of time and you
still go and do it no one's watching
like when you're starting skateboarding
no one's you don't have a crowd you're
doing this for you it's your fight it's
your personal fight and you make it and
now because of phones you got video so
you can show your friends so there's a
bonus but
but it's you might not realize it at the
time but that's how you achieve stuff in
life is
it doesn't work out a lot but don't stop
like never stop
with the plan
you've inspired me i'm going to go out
and buy a skateboard with training
wheels on it now
yeah i was i was
[Laughter]
i was not with that plan at all until
you said training
and i was like okay yeah maybe that's
okay keep those wheels on
work
we're just getting some 215s and be all
right yeah you'd be fine
just big white chunks you should not
coming through
congratulations on the thing with dior
in the the whole clothing line yeah oh
that was just they just invited me to
their fashion oh they didn't have a oh
no no no no they made him stuffed come
on dude don't i would yes i was if it
was me i'd be like okay let me tell you
a little bit about dior and me he
wearing any of the dior they gave you
he didn't give it to us he gave it to
other people i missed out on a [ __ ]
fanny pack gave it to somebody else i
was like oh you did think of me next but
but i mean what they were trying to do
i mean listen when something gets
worldly popular
dior has skate clothes at their they
made stuff for him yeah they did and
they they had a couple designers that
had skate backgrounds that were working
on that collaboration and so they
definitely were were influenced by
skating you could tell with the shoes
because they were very 90s puffy shoes
tell them about the pants
what's that the pants did the color they
made it and why oh so the pants i was
wearing they looked they look kind of
acid washed they said no it's the color
of the concrete and then a skatepark
and i was like that's cool dior made
custom pants
sorry i would just be like this all day
could you grab me custom pants did i cry
yeah no did you say cry see i'm with you
i would have teared up a little bit did
you make these pants to match the bowl
because i'm skateboarding you guys
really mean a lot to me like i would
just that would have yeah it's i mean
it's incredibly
the vision of that to say we're gonna
make him pants from the place okay
here's here's how it came to be they
they hit me up and they said hey you
want to come see our fashion show and
i i've never really been invited to
stuff like that on a small scale i have
and then
um
someone said you guys you know my wife
was like let's get dior let's let's go
check it out why not yeah the arm and uh
suddenly i realized that suddenly i
realized that it was very much there was
a lot of skate influence in the line
that they were showing yeah and then i
realized why they wanted me there
because i thought i was just want to
grab bag of people like yeah get him
there he's got a social media following
i don't know why they wanted you there
yeah and then before i knew it i'm i'm
out of fitting
and they they're you know they got a
little clear and and
they gave me gear they gave gear to my
wife and set us up in this crazy hotel
room nearby the show and then
and then we went to the thing we were
sitting up front it was cool
this cool [ __ ] yeah right
i mean i don't i don't benefit from that
necessarily like
down the line well you know you're
saying it's a line like i have nothing
to do
but yeah but it was it was a cool
experience and and i appreciate that
that they honored skateboarding like
that that just shows how far we've come
in what we were doing
it was the furthest thing from cool when
we were kids and
it's it's the highlight of the vogue
fashion show incredible
i mean he plays himself down he has to
stay grounded or whatever but i'm not
but you would have teared up though i
mean i would have
when he told me he was gone i'm like
what i mean did he give you sunglasses
what kind of shoes did you get he's like
i don't know
for all the times that the [ __ ] sun
went down and you couldn't see where you
were going and you might have to pack it
inside we'll do it tomorrow and you're
with your friend and it's getting dark
if you play baseball in the park or what
whatever and then you know it gets dark
and you can't throw the ball anymore and
you go [ __ ] it we'll do it tomorrow for
all of those times that you went to
found
something you could skate on and learn
the trick on that was just there either
in a ravine or somewhere and you're like
[ __ ] this place is great man we got to
tell our friends and come back here for
all those times that kids gave up or
kids got hurt and kids said i don't want
to skateboard anymore they put it in the
closet and then one day they're like i
got my skateboard in there i'm going to
do it again and they didn't quit just
like participation trophies that it's a
tremendous honor
for that to happen oh yeah absolutely i
mean dior
was selling nike dior uh shoes for five
thousand dollars a pair but i mean
they're dior but
the commercialization of skating it's
it's great to be
uh included but also
for times that it stopped and had to
start again
to see that happen was is is amazing for
skateboarding yeah that dior would say
we're going to make
these shoes
from the 90s
yeah
yeah it's crazy yeah it makes it good
for the the next generation which is you
know because i got so much from
skateboarding i really would like to
give back in any way possible and he
sets up things for people we don't even
know about yet in the future that are
going to have
a career right you know like i want to
be a skateboarder and you know when i
was a kid you'd be like well then are
you going to get a job
but now yeah it is it's much more
available
what have you what have you not done
that you that you've wanted to do
i'm going to say
no no in life i mean there's so many
different things in in in life that you
that you haven't done
um
be a really good comedian that's what
i'm working on that was what you want to
do yeah
that's it i don't wanna i don't care
about the fame or money really yeah i
just wanna be good like you guys what
what would you
consider what would you have to do
or accomplish for you to con to say i'm
a really good comedian to have a special
maybe a netflix special no because i can
tell there's people out there that don't
have specials that are really good bobby
lee is one of the funniest people i've
ever seen you're never special so to me
it's more
i want to go up there
and like i see these tim dillons and all
these guys where i know i'm going to own
it and i do own it and i rip and
everybody goes wow that was hilarious
and i go home that's what i want
do you live in los angeles yeah okay
my friend runs ruby tuesdays at the
laugh factory yeah and i would love to
get you a spot on a tuesday night over
there yeah and he's yeah fully okay
i'm really glad i brought that up now
okay no to me it's i just did the
comments
i would love for you to go down there
in san diego i'll be down there that
night to watch you in here yeah you're
not gonna get up there no
maybe do some skateboarding
but you'll hear them [ __ ] laughing
from forever
it's a guy you want that's a guy that
laughs makes you feel good when you're
up there so i would love to do that uh i
would be honest all right thank you so
much
and we never really spent this much time
over we met you know we've met a few
times over the years yeah yeah but it's
an honor to have you guys sitting down
it's honored to have you here it's an
honor to meet you thanks for having me
congratulations on everything and all
the injured congratulations on all the
injuries
because without them none of us would
[ __ ] be here yeah now they tell they
they create stories they do they really
they really do man i mean there's
nothing there's no replacement
from pain good things can come yeah as
long as you come back as long as that's
the end of it like if no matter what it
is if you
come back we had a guy on our podcast
the other day that has brain cancer and
he skates and he's got this thing that
he's got to wear on his head
that like does a backpack that feeds and
he has a backpack that feeds it with a
helmet on because he won't take because
he won't stop skateboarding so he
figured out a way to have this on while
skateboarding
people like that man where i'm like you
know i got a lot of injuries i'm like
shut the [ __ ] up
you're right how did you guys decide
yeah i know bring cancer how did you
guys decide to do the podcast uh we used
to do a show on siriusxm
and uh it was it was and you didn't pay
and then he went on to have his own show
on the same channel he basically was the
voice of the channel he got paid really
well for that for a while in the end i
did pretty good yeah and then uh and
then we both
i left he got let go of serious and then
a couple years later
he was talking about doing podcasts and
i said why don't we just try to do one
and here we are covered
sell cars so they cut they gave stone
all that money and they cut
myself and jenny mccarthy and a couple
of people that got paid too much ah
because i also said like
they were in contract negotiations and i
was like just so you know because i can
tell things look
bad for you guys
if you're gonna cup me like my check
just just fire me because i'm not gonna
do that
because i already felt like
they bottled me you know and i was like
if i'm not gonna get exactly what i want
i'm gonna i wanna do podcasting like i'm
it's free speech a younger generation of
a broadcaster and podcasting always made
more sense to me when i watched it come
up and i was on siriusxm i was i would
tell them hey
you see these guys like we need to do
what these guys are doing or we're going
to get left in the dirt and then i feel
like that's what happened
do you think that's the same thing that
happened to netflix because netflix was
running the table
and i think they just let
i think they got lazy dude i feel like
their content became [ __ ] they they were
running the table weren't they they were
on yeah yeah they were running the table
now yeah they're losing so much right
now and they've just let like 500 people
go and smile because it's not worth
watching and then there's all these new
things that come up where you're like oh
that's just as good wait that might even
be better because that i've watched it i
like netflix but in the end it sort of
became
a habit where you turn your tv on and
you go there and i'm like
i'm just surfing going no no no and i'm
like you know what the [ __ ] happened to
netflix it's that you know that's very
true like i
used to watch netflix all the time and
now
uh but i mean it's not the cycle of
things isn't when things just get kind
of too big and they don't understand
how to maintain it's not sustainable
right and they would make they were
making movies so they were a studio but
they weren't like like paramount tv just
started or peacock yeah or all those
other play discovery had discovery plus
hulu and they were creating content but
also they weren't they weren't making a
studio to me to make your channel
your your your streaming service
a a studio means you're not going to see
a movie for two years but if you're
streaming you can you can get it up and
get it on like that and i think that's
where they got left behind right that
they seemed lazy they were trying to
make they were trying to make movies
when they should have been making
content yeah i still watch netflix so do
i but obviously
there is one good documentary on have
you seen love on the spectrum
yours is on hbo isn't it hbo yeah yeah
wait you got a documentary
[Laughter]
i would have watched that if that was
that what's it called nightstalker
search for sure oh because you're the
guy that got that [ __ ]
yeah so that was thank you for that i'm
sure everybody has already thanked you
he yeah and he was the he was the
detective that said it's the same guy
and everybody else said that's [ __ ]
they motherfucked him all over and then
he said it's they said no it's got to be
more than one guy he's like he's the guy
that said it's one guy yeah
so wow we got him hey thank you for your
service oh thank you
also he was at a place where his own one
of his own officers uh shot at him
thank you for your service
a sheriff there was a guy knew on the
job
it was a highway
i mean he thought we were bad guys
playing close okay that's still kind of
an accident shot at us his partner was
saying hey they're cops he says i don't
know that either shut out them
[Laughter]
did you punch him or anything no no
i just hurry i just told hey you better
you better take your business because it
was after a guy that they were trying to
stop
and they had hooked him up and i said if
you don't take care of they're going to
lynch him you know worry about that
first because i learned a long time
going
in combat you panic somebody dies or
gets hurt yeah now is not a time to
panic take care of that [ __ ] don't what
about after that did you punch him in
your face fired no he got fired they
rolled him up he left man it'd be hard
for me not to punch that dude in the
face did you just [ __ ] shoot at me
let me know when you want to go to the
live factory thank you guys
appreciate your time thank you guys this
was one of the best podcasts
that i've been involved with you and and
i thank you you know what it's different
because when you usually kiss ass after
the guests have left so oh this is
good
thanks man
i'll tell rob dudek he said hello
do you know him
apparently
[Laughter]
even rob gotta let go from mtv that'll
be that's wait did he
i think so yeah ridiculous is still on
i think it's that now they're not in
production anymore oh oh i didn't know
running the table over there man yeah he
was i think he still is i was going to
say he probably yeah that guy reruns
he's an advanced human being always what
was that show that was that show was
just like almost like what what uh
jackson
and they wouldn't pick it up
and then tasho's show came out and then
they picked up his so he claims that he
had the idea i believe right i don't
think rob is a guy that knows how to
steal stuff from people but
he also has
many backup plans and many other
businesses and he always has back in the
skateboarding day where we were only
skateboarders and there was probably
only 10 skateboarders that made real
money i remember going over to his
apartment turbo porsche in the driveway
and the first person i ever met that had
multiple diamond necklaces not one
like 25. and i remember back in the day
we were all trying to get one you know i
mean i had one and i was like that's my
whole life i can't afford a house but
i've got a gold chain with a diamond on
it and he was like yeah look at these
and i was like oh my
you have a jewelry store in your house
that guy's always been ahead of the game
he's amazing i can't wait to go back and
talk to my grandson about you guys it
was great thank you tell him that tell
him that that tony hawk signed a
skateboard for for him but somebody took
it on the way
you